I think we both met Chris
Farley around the same time.
I remember very clearly when
he came to Saturday Night Live.
And he was waiting for
an interview with Lorne
and I think he had
to wait for two days
outside Lorne's office.
And so I ended up just
clowning around with
this great new guy I'd never
met before named Chris Farley.
You met him probably shortly
after he was hired for
Saturday Night Live.
Because you knew Lorne
you knew Lorne Michaels.
Yes
So how did you is that when you met Chris,
'cause I know you
eventually worked with him
in Tommy Boy,
but you met him I think at
Lauren's house is that correct?
I met him I met him at Lauren's wedding,
and how you there's certain people in life
that for whatever reason you
remember exactly where you were
when you met them.
And think about many people
that we meet famous not famous,
and we don't remember where
we met them for the first time
or what they were doing
or how they were standing.
Farley was one of those guys,
probably because he was
packed into a suit that
was 17 times too small for him.
Right.
And sweat Like he had
jumped into Lake Michigan,
but he was standing by the porta potties.
And then of course his first
acting job in a movie was
in Wayne's World 2.
And then of course we
did Tommy Boy together
and I loved him.
He was funny and he and Spade.
they would fight over me
like I was the hot girl.
They were they would
get very jealous of who
was spending time with me.
And it really made me laugh.
I understand that.
I get where they're coming from.
I really understand that.
I'm always jealous when I hear
that you're spending time with others.
And one quick Farley story
is he loved to eat steak.
And I took him to a steak house
when we wrapped Tommy Boy,
and he had two full bone in Porter houses.
Upon each bite of the two
full bonus edge Porter houses,
he put an entire cube of butter,
on every bite.
And when I was horrified like
Farley what are you doing,
he said it needs a hat.
(laughs)
Oh God bless him.
Yes, what a brilliantly funny guy.
I've never I've never
eaten steak, every bite
of steak I eat to this day.
I go I wonder if I
should put a hat on this.
(laughs)
Maybe not,
Surgeon General might disagree.
Yeah
No.
Yeah.